welcome back to Facebook with our sense
today was disgraced former Health
secretary Matt Hancock's turned to face
the public inquiry to have a government
handle the covid pandemic Hancock said
that UK's preparations were too focused
on the consequences of a disaster rather
than how to stop it over the course of
three hours the man in charge of public
health throughout Kobe so the plans put
in place to protect Care Homes were
terrible yet of course previously said
that he put a protective Ring Of Steel
around them I'm joined Now by Care Home
manager and owner of Crabtree car Homes
care homes in West Yorkshire David
Crabtree and by talk TV's International
editor I'm a journalist behind the
lockdown files Isabel oh shots Isabel
sum up today
well today was Matt Hancock's effort to
set the record straight and to try to
convince everybody that he's sorry for
what happened we saw a a performance
there of somebody who was knew he had to
go through the motions of telling people
that he's sorry for each and every one
of the deaths I don't say that he didn't
mean that from the heart but I don't
think that will satisfy everybody who
has an ax to grind about how he managed
the pandemic he had decided before going
in that he wanted to make one key
argument and he kept returning to it
throughout today's evidence even when it
wasn't relevant you know to the
irritation actually of the Barrister and
his key argument was this that
everything went wrong was primarily due
to the government having ruled out
lockdowns as a strategy before the
pandemic happened so his argument is
that pandemic planning should have
focused on the use of lockdowns rather
than avoiding lockdowns a lot of people
will say it's a precise opposite that
should have happened well let's take a
look at what Hancock said about how
sorry he is he's been apologizing for
almost everything for the last year
foundly sorry for each death that has
occurred and I also understand
why for some it will be hard to take
that apology from me I understand that I
get it
but it is honest and heartfelt and I'm
not very good at talking about my
emotions and how I feel
um but that is
honest and true
it's just it's just a phony handcuff
absolute phony honestly I just think
he's an actor when he puts on this stuff
we saw it when he went in the jungle
we've seen it ever since the fake tears
he shed to me on GMB about vaccines and
let's get to care homes for a moment
this is a guy of course who repeatedly
boasted about the protective Ring Of
Steel that he had put around Care Homes
this is what he said about Care Homes
today
we didn't even have the data and this is
the work that was ongoing before the
pandemic which is why this statement
here from the guardian reported from the
garden is inaccurate
um there was work on going to try to
find out even the basics of the
provision of social care for instance
how many Care Homes are operating right
now in the UK that was a fact that we
did not know
well let me come to David Crabtree David
we've spoken many times since the start
of the pandemic during it and after
Hancock had always said he put a
protective Ring Of Steel around the uh
Care Homes he also at the start of a
pandemic boasted how well prepared the
country was for this kind of pandemic
neither of those things were true and
today he basically admitted he hadn't
got a clue about what was going on with
our Care Homes and it was terrible
what's your reaction to that
I'm hopeful that this is the last time
that we see this individual in in public
other than on a pantomime playing the
villain at Christmas
he is such a self-serving lying
inadequate sociopath he should be
sponsored by Kleenex tissues every time
he appears in public
the brain then goes back to those awful
awful times where people not not just
the elderly this was dedicated social
Care staff unprotected which he then
said we had a ring of protection around
the man's deluded he believes what he's
saying therefore he can create this
emotion within himself but it's a lie
and I just wish now that this is an
enter the the poor families who lost we
all we lost Care staff we lost Social
Care staff we lost dedicated NHS staff
the man was not fit for purpose he was
the primary man who was supposed to look
at the contingency plans and he believed
some rumor that we were the best in
Europe
who told him this
I I have no idea who he told it but
shouldn't he have checked shouldn't the
captain of the ship have checked before
we all sang yeah I completely agree let
me bring Isabel I mean you know him very
well you wrote this book with him
um I just think he's a phony Hancock and
I think he's delusional and I think he's
desperately trying to reel off the hook
which frankly it seems more and more
certain he is firmly implanted on
there was an extraordinary moment during
the evidence today where Matt Hancock
admitted that he and his Department
didn't even know how many Care Homes
there are in England you would have
thought that this was basic but he
admitted that the whole setup is so
dysfunctional there is so little
coordination although his title is
secretary or was a secretary of state
for Health and Social care he had the
top responsibility for it but actually
didn't have a clue what was going on
there was a very uh it was a pretty Grim
quite literally a bit of footage when he
left the inquiry and the Grim Reaper
literally someone dressed as the Grim
Reaper appeared on the other side of the
street watch this
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean pretty devastating imagery for
Hancock and frankly I think he deserves
it I think his handling of this pandemic
was absolutely disastrous but the thing
is that the yeah
absolutely believes that he did nothing
wrong I mean one of the hardest things
when I was working with him was to get
him to admit that there were some
failures because you can't have a book
which just says I'm a hero and
everything was brilliant and he really
struggled to come up with examples of
areas where we got things wrong well
exactly well he can't because he's
delusional David you want to come in
there
yeah it's it's it isn't that we got
things wrong it was new and it happened
across the world we were watching France
and Italy and elderly people in Care
Homes die months two months before it
came across the water what compounds it
and what makes me still angry is that he
lied despite the facts this is why your
comment and my comment that is
delusional a delusion is a false belief
that cannot be altered by reason or
factual evidence to the contrary and he
still does he said he gets it he doesn't
get it no he doesn't get it I completely
agree he was so arrogant you know in his
pronouncements there's a ring of Steel
we've never been better prepared none of
it was true and we now know from his own
mouth and this inquiry he knew it wasn't
true he hadn't got a clue about care
homes or how safe they were what sort of
Ring Of Steel there was a protective
shield whatever the phrase was that he
used
um look there's gonna be a lot more
coming off on the discharge of elderly
into care homes which everybody every
scientist that told him don't push
people into Care Homes it's a breeding
ground he did and that caused masses of
deaths 20 30 000 people died in Care
Homes uh Isabel finally you've had
access to a lot of WhatsApp exchanges
there is a series of whatsapps involving
Matt Hancock I think from March April
early in the pandemic we should have
just never materialize where are those
and it's really disappointing that he
wasn't challenged on that during the
exchanges today
um I I still want to know what's
happened to those messages because the
missing messages missing as far as I'm
concerned because they were not shared
with me are from March 2020 which is the
key time for this particular module of
the covert inquiry which is all about
how prepared were we we need to see
those messages yes we do Isabel and
David thank you very much thank you both
for joining me I appreciate it